aujourd'hui je voudrais qu'on parle de
cette histoire il est témoin du jour ils
sont trop c'est l'histoire d'une belle
demande au mariage gâchée par une
attitude excécrable et par le racisme la
semaine dernière benjamin voulait
demander sa chérie en mariage et il
avait prévu de faire les choses en grand
et jabra merci beaucoup mais c'est vrai
vous êtes très beau tous les deux
merci à fabrice qu'ils allaient très
bien ensemble merci sais rien mais c'est
vrai vraiment alors vous et elle ce
n'est pas la témoin c'est votre avocat
bon le dit roland
voilà merci aux données d'être là et
donc ils réservent un appartement dans
le 16e arrondissement de paris
sauf que tout ne se passe pas comme
prévu arrivé sur place il va subir des
remarques racistes on lui refuse même
l'accès à l'appartement regard des
sujets et benjamin et sa fiancée
maurane entre on a la chance d'avoir et
natacha à l'efb liant dans avocate est
avec nous vous allez voir vous allez
tout nous raconter cette histoire
scandaleuse
on voulait absolument gagner ce soir et
voilà vous payez venir hier je voulais
dit il ya c'est vrai qu'il ya un match
de foot donc voilà j'ai préféré voilà
que ce soit aujourd'hui parce que je
pense qu'il ya plus de monde qui va nous
regarder parce que je voulais absolument
mettre en lumière cette à terre regarde
ses propos tenus par un propriétaire
d'un appartement à paris sont la suite
d'une demande en mariage qui a viré au
cauchemar
le 24 mai dernier benjamin king gombert
réservé un logement dans le 16e
arrondissement
il devait demander la main de sa
compagne mais une fois arrivés sur place
le concierge de l'appartement lui refuse
d'entrer après ce premier épisode à
caractère raciste baja main qui a quand
même réussi à demander en mariage sa
compagne décide d'appeler le
propriétaire de l'appartement en
question pour obtenir des explications
mais à sa grande surprise ce dernier
tient des propos encore plus choquant
que le concierge
merci d'être avec nous benjamin et
morale on l'a entendu vous avez quand
même demandé trois futures femmes là je
vois là donc ça c'est l'essentiel
l'essentiel est préservé si vous voulez
que j'anime le mariage d aucuns soucis
donc tout a commencé quand vous avez
réservé cet appartement dans le 16e
arrondissement de paris au moment de
réserver l'appartement tout se passe
bien tout se passe bien
j'ai eu l'idée de lui faire une demande
en mariage le jour de son anniversaire
et de semaine à l'avant ce j'ai essayé
de de trouver un appartement chic sur
paris pour essayer de changer un peu de
cadres sur et du coup je réserve tout se
passe bien
et les lendemains j'appelle le monsieur
du coup parce que on peut appeler du
coup compte en réserve on peut appeler
pour avoir plus de renseignements par
rapport à la réservation nation et donc
pendant deux semaines c'était pas
possible parfois me raccrocher au nez
parfois on me répondait pas alors que
j'appelais juste pour avoir plus
d'explications par rapport à ma
réservation alors le 24 mai vous arrivez
donc sur place et là vous avez croisé le
concierge qui va tout simplement vous
refuser l'accès au bâtiment
voilà donc j'arrive moi j'arrive sur
place et j'avais plein de sacs que
j'avais acheté des cadeaux j'avais
acheté un bouquet de fleurs des
chocolats et donc du coup j'arrive sur
place le concierge il arrivé au début me
regarder bizarrement j'avais pas compris
pourquoi
et la première question qui me pose
c'est vous allez être connus dans
l'appartement et là je réponds bah comme
je vous ai dit un message on sera
endormi rade à l'appartement mais par
contre je compte inviter soit une copine
à elle ou où sa mère pour juste pour
être témoins et participer à la surprise
est le monsieur il refuse l'accès il me
dit je vous laisserai pas rentrer vous
avez aimé de la musique on vous connaît
vous allez ramener toute l'afrique c'est
incroyable aussi d'avoir des abrutis
pareil encore comme ça c'est c'est fou
alors vous lui dites moi vous avez déjà
payé en plus j'avais déjà payé bien sûr
elle avait déjà payé donc du coup
j'avais pas compris c'était sous la
pluie
je lui ai dit mais monsieur c'est pas
possible
la main copine doit arriver sur paris à
17 heures il est 16 heures
vous me dites que je peux pas rentrer
c'est pas possible
alors là ça s'arrête pas là parce que
vous avez découvert que le gestionnaire
de l'appartement que vous aviez réservé
ne va pas vous défendre
bien au contraire il va avoir des propos
encore plus scandaleux vous décidé de
l'appeler vous est une amie et les
propos sont extrêmement choquant vous
aviez enregistré la conversation on va
écouter ce qui vous a dit c'est
incroyable écoutez à vous prenez mon
argent monsieur vous me prêtez de sale
[ __ ] avons traité de noir mais c'est
normal
vous êtes des menteurs d'accord donc ont
aidé on est des matins qu'on ait des
menteurs c'est bien ça fait mal on est
tellement ridicule que vous demandez
vous m'entendez est-ce que vous
m'entendez messieurs d'accord on peut
communiquer normalement vous m'entendez
d'accord vous êtes en train d élaborer
cimetière la glace en cédant bcg les
mêmes paquebot c'est vrai encore qu'on
entend donc là ils vont menacer aussi
physiquement par lui je dis quoi passer
moi votre votre adresse jeu arrive en
scooter je vous écraser comme georges
floyd c'était vraiment des menaces des
mort c'était c'était incroyable
c'est c'était choquant c'est je vois que
vous arrivez à garder tous les deux
votre calme lors de l'appel téléphonique
vous êtes extrêmement calme en plus
c'est incroyable parce que je trouve ca
erratique de votre calme parce qu'il y
en a plein qui se serait parti vraiment
encore plus loin et qui est vraiment
bravo à vous parce qu'un contraire ses
côtés un téléphone le propriétaire bien
sûr donc il est même pas courageux il
affronte paris cas de 21 ans et vous
menacé de porter plainte
et cet homme vous fait clairement
comprendre à vous et en votre âme et
votre future femme c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vous là en fait là nous en fait
quand ça s'est passé le 24 mai l'avait
enfin le lendemain du coup on a appelé à
résister nous deux d'accord et la voilà
c'est là que ça a commencé là oui là il
y avait là vous êtes d'abord voilà et
après ça c'est peut-être ces deux jours
après qu'il est parti avec une amie à
moi pour aller là sont les écouter ce
qui vous dit que vous pensez vraiment
que les noirs on a dit nadal mais c'est
pas ben quoi c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
que c'est la justice ou fermer l'accès à
la justice
je suis désolé mais c'est comme ça vous
n'avez pas d'amis qu'ils ont foutu tout
s'est tellement fier lorsque l'arrière
ben le retard vous avez très bien fait
en tout cas d'enregistrer les
conversations
vous avez été je pense être extrêmement
choqué par ce que vous avez entendu
c'est seafood entendre des propos comme
ça et ce qui est plus grave c'est que
ces faits deux histoires eh oui deux
histoires jour celle assez similaires et
des insultes similaire en quelques jours
et là je m'adresse à vous m il faut
qu'il ait des sanctions il faut
absolument porter cette affaire en
justice fauqué des sanctions et je pense
qu'il faut des sanctions exemplaires et
très vite et nous on va on va suivre la
faire et on dira vraiment s'il ya eu des
sanctions si on n'a pas eu on le dira
ici parce que ce serait inadmissible
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pour
l'instant on est tous pour l'instant il
ya des plaintes qui ont été déposées
pour injure mais aussi pour menaces de
mort il ya aussi un délit qui s'appelle
le délit de discriminer qui est prime
sous le code pénal et nous ce qu'on veut
aujourd'hui c'est que ce délice sept
personnages soient poursuivis dans le
cadre de ce délit de discriminer votre
plante a été prise au sérieux
voilà très sérieusement c'est suivi en
ce moment là c'est parquet de paris qui
est saisie de la sphère qui en charge de
la faire on doit aller remettre tous les
enregistrements à la police
très prochainement et les investigations
vont se porter sur la recherche de
l'identité de l'auteur parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a un numéro de
téléphone mais on ne sait pas qui se
cache derrière ce téléphone bâton alors
nous aussi on avait le numéro on a ici
de rappeler alors ça ne répond plus
sachez-le parce qu'on sait c'est j'ai
essayé de l'appeler
hier plusieurs fois apparemment ça ne
répond plus à ce numéro
voilà donc aujourd'hui on attendait
aussi on va essayer de faire bouger les
choses et l'essai de retrouver cette
personne mais c'est vrai que je vous dit
hier avec nos équipes quand on a préparé
l'émission money on a halluciné
si ces caisses qui risque aujourd'hui ce
monsieur parce que pour les pour les
infractions qu'on lui reproche
il risque trois ans d'emprisonnement et
45000 euros d'amendé à savoir que par
contre pour les injures l'injure non
publique c'est une contravention de 4e
classe ça veut dire 135 euros d'amendé
oui ce serait quand même un petit peu
léger si on avait uniquement cette
infraction là qui étaient poursuivis
aujourd'hui on attend quand même des ce
que vous y croyez vraiment aux sanctions
oui oui parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec les médias on a des
personnes qui sont de plus en plus
informés sur leurs droits
on a de moins en moins de personnes qui
acceptent finalement qu'on met en
conflit différentes populations et
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
est effectivement des sanctions
exemplaires ce qu'on aimerait plutôt
maintenant c'est avoir une plateforme
qui existent pour pour dénoncer tous les
faits de discrimination
un peu comme ce qu'on voit pour les
violences conjugales parce
qu'aujourd'hui
monsieur a été obligé de passer par des
associations pour pouvoir aller déposer
plainte pour pouvoir se renseigner sur
la manière dont il fallait déposer
plainte que je trouve que vous avez très
bien fait d'aller au bout de la sphère
de porter plainte d'apporter cette
affaire en justice parce que il ya plein
de gens et je les comprends aussi se
réduiront je fais insulter au téléphone
voilà et je vais passer à autre chose
vous avez très bien fait parce que et
cette affaire on va la suivre parce
qu'on veut que ce soit un exemple et on
va suivre on va dire les sanctions qui
ont été faites et qui ont été prises
parce qu'il faut qu'il ait sanction
parce que ça je vous dis tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous suivent la schl
walla sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est un déferlement de haine contre
cette personne c'est inadmissible et
vraiment je
je suivrai je vais suivre la faire pour
vraiment qu'il ait des sanctions
aujourd'hui encore triste ou les deux
quand vous voyez ça oui bien sûr va bien
sûr parce que depuis qu'on a entendu ça
on est mais on est tétanisé on est
stressés on est c'est la première fois
que ça vous arrive est la première fois
là c'était vraiment mais nous ce que ce
qui nous choque et ce qui saute choqué
les téléspectateurs c'est que je vous
lis en une semaine il ya eu 2 de cas
similaires en pc des cas qui ont été
médiatisés donc imaginer tous les cas
tous les autres cas qu'il ya des cas
médiatisés en quelques jours et les
mêmes propos
et c'est ça qui m'inquiète fortement oui
il faut savoir qu'il ya un très faible
pourcentage de gens victimes de racisme
qui porte plainte c'est ça qu'ils
n'osent pas c'est exactement donc
vraiment ce que vous avez fait c'est
exemplaire même si c'est dur parce que
c'est en médiatisant comme ça et que ça
fera avancer les choses et qui va les
voir au plus haut niveau
la prise en compte de ça il faut durcir
la sanction contre le racisme
donc bravo à vous franchement il fallait
faire ça et c'est très courageux très
jeune alors vous avez pu la demande et
vêtements décemment quand même oui oui
ça devenait vraiment à le faire ce jour
là parce que c'était le jour de son
anniversaire donc ça s'était bien passé
quand même lui ça va ça s'est bien passé
s'est pas vraiment ce que je voulais
parce que ça faisait deux semaines que
je connaissais l'appartement je
regardais j'avais prévu de faire des
choses par rapport à cet appartement là
et c'était un peu dommage que vraiment à
la dernière minute que ça se passe comme
ça je vous souhaite beaucoup de bonheur
à tous les deux en tout cas ces six mois
je peux vous faire un petit cadeau ça
serait que je j'aimerais bien vous
offrir le voyage de noces conne
merci encore et on va gérer ça parce que
ça me ferait plaisir et puis comme ça on
part voilà onze par et puis on essaie de
suivre cette affaire on va sur l on sera
en vacances à partir du 10 juin mais dès
la rentrée on va suivre toutes ces
affaires hambourg parlera également du
bras ce qu on parlera également de cette
affaire parce qu'on va faire un suivi
déjà fermée